whoa what's with the cast I sprained my
wrist oh no what happened don't worry
about it I'm fine yeah geez Amy back off
leave the guy alone all right everybody
bring it in Bring It
so he wouldn't say what happened which
can only mean one thing he's in a fight
a fight no he did it doing something
he's embarrassed by like smiling only
question is how do you hurt your arms
smiling it could be a sports injury I
sprained my wrist in college playing
field hockey men's field hockey yeah
it's much more violent than the women's
game we're not allowed to wear anything
that protects our breasts attention
everyone how can hear you speculating
about the nature and origin of my injury
from my office I tripped over an uneven
sidewalk I did not think it was relevant
to your jobs the jobs which you should
all be doing right now get to work
do you want to know how I actually hurt
my wrist
yes I was hula hooping Kevin and I
attend a class for fitness and for fun
oh my god I've mastered all the moves
the pizza toss
the tornado the Scorpion the oopsy
doodle
why are you telling me this
because no one is will ever believe you
no no
sick son of none of us guys I have a
great idea for a prank beforehold comes
in I'm gonna put ink on the podium where
he puts his hands I don't think he'll
fall for that I did how I haven't even
opened this yet I guess it's unrelated
Captain hold hates pranks this is gonna
backfire man ugh fine I'll tone it down
I'll move his Podium a foot to the left
what
would be so angry okay five inches five
three three one one all right I'll move
it a half inch fine it's your funeral oh
worst prank ever stupid Hulk's not even
gonna notice good morning
you guys it
the podium is
you're crazy how did you pull this off
I'm here I'm here I'm here
you can start the meeting now the
meeting is over you're late you missed
roll call and the tutorial on using the
new copier six years and no matter how
hard I try I still can't get you to
understand The Importance of Being
punctual maybe you should just give up
and accept me for who I am no I will
break you right now while you were out
being tardy I was hard at work devising
a special punishment I've crafted an
intricate personal high five with
everyone in this office except you what
but you hate high fives yes every minute
of it was hell but it'll be worse for
you Squad dismissed goodbye DS
allude into a family
goodbye Jeffers
goodbye Santiago double fist bump
reverse explosion into a p Townsend
strum
all right that was terrible terrible but
it's over now and I made it through
goodbye Leonard from Xerox what no no
the copy guy
the next time I see you I'd like you to
be wearing a necktie oh uh actually the
last Captain didn't care if we wore ties
well your new captain does and more
importantly he cares that you follow his
direct orders
no surprises from the corner two
gunshots shoulder and chest none of the
neighbors heard or saw anything and
what's worse Santiago struck out with a
92 year old that is not accurate sir
wait you hooked up with him all right
hit the pawn shops in canvas the
neighborhood and while you're out you
can buy yourself a tie oh actually sir
I'm wearing a tie right now check it out
secret tie
that's fine work detective thank you
very much sir Testament to what can be
achieved when you dress appropriately
let's pound it out
you know what such fine police work
let's share it with the whole team
Santiago boyo Diaz get in here bring
everyone and a camera that's not
necessary
work of the fine Master detective Jay
Peralta yeah let's have a hand everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
it's Heist time
I thought you get a head start on Heist
prep good luck I'm already dressed well
I'm also dressed and I made breakfast
wait where are my eggs in my belly yeah
now get a move on it's Heist time I love
Halloween and that brings us to five
minutes ago when Amy came to your office
and told you that I had been arrested I
knew she's the only one you would
believe because frankly she's usually
too lame to take part in these kinds of
things and as you walked over here
Charles awkwardly stepped himself
through your window and opened your safe
we had the four numbers of your code
which meant there were 24 possible
combinations for Charles to try that
could take up to four minutes which is
why I really dragged out this
explanation I mean really stretched it I
don't know if you noticed but there were
times where I was like what am I even
talking about this isn't a
but now four minutes is up which means
Boyle is either on the other side of
that door holding your metal
or I've lost
well Captain it seems that Jake isn't
the only person you underestimate
20 seconds to spare
game over captain
check me I think you mean Checkmate you
really need to learn how to play chess
how did you get everyone to help you I
appealed to their sense of teamwork and
camaraderie with a rousing speech that
would put Shakespeare to shame
lockdown ridiculed Made To Wear Ties but
no more for today we defeat him and that
worked no oh no not at all my speech did
not Inspire them
come on so I bribed them I told them
that if we pulled this off I would do
all of their paperwork and since you're
doing all my paperwork I'm impressed
Peralta
hold on
thank you sir
in fact the thing that you failed to see
Captain teamwork captain
sir
he's not coming back my watch is right
here no I made a switch that's a fake no
this one's a fake
what
no
you were behind all this
hate me like cross blueheim plays the
flute but how I've been planning this
step for three months I know but I've
been planning it
for a year last Halloween after you won
the bet I went back to my office to do
everyone's paperwork but I didn't know
paperwork I started to plop my revenge I
began by creating a word cloud but how
could you possibly have known I was
going to try and steal your watch I knew
you were trying to take something
important to me during the year I drew
your attention
to my watch
you're eight minutes late you're 14
minutes late you're three minutes early
in Chicago
you annoyed me into stealing it exactly
now you had a Target but you needed a
plan fortunately walked through the door
handcuffed to Diaz scumbag pickpocket is
Jan McCreary you can take anything off
of anyone anything
[Music]
look on your face
priceless
I put McCreery into my employee
immediately fast forward to this morning
you commenced your plan McCrary stole my
watch and then replaced it with a
replica and while you celebrated
McCreary put my watch back in my pocket
the watch never left my person
I can see that you're enjoying this not
nearly as much as I enjoyed phase two
Duke while you met with McCreary
Santiago placed a fire hydrant in front
of your car which she then towed away
next I had to take Charles out of the
equation he had a badge and a gun and he
would do anything to help you enter a
parade of drunks that separated the two
of you long enough for Terry to kidnap
Charles then two bears spilled their
drinks on you and stole your wallet
those beers Scully and Hitchcock I can't
put my head off if Terry kidnapped
Charles how did Charles tell me to get
on the party bus eight months ago at a
morning briefing I told the squad that a
group of thieves was targeting party
buses so I could record Charles saying
[Music]
you'll never knowingly betray me with
your jacket and she was gone you didn't
look like a cop but you still had your
badge that is until you entered
the party bus Rosa's feline dancing
distracted you as a mysterious party or
stole your badge on Halloween
it was you in The Mask you slice son of
a well done but I do have to ask
those guys at the impound did they
really smash my car no in fact I had
them wash it
good one Captain you can't wash a car
so how'd you convince the whole Squad to
betray me what'd you offer them I asked
them if they wanted to embarrass you and
they instantly said yes not gonna lie
that turns me on a little bit
so in addition to the five weeks of free
overtime
I believe I mowed one more thing yes
here we go one second
all right
[Music]
very well Captain Raymond Holt you are
an amazing police captain slash genius
[Applause]